well
a man is in
critical condition after a shooting near the center
of the valley how are you greetings cristian
casares the streets of buen cercas of
spring mount he were closed
during the investigation this morning the
shooting happened near jainer streets
and well until the  At this time
the cause is unknown The coach of a
high school in our dates has been
arrested and charged
with sexual misconduct with a student The
Clark County School District says that
21-year-old Michael Jones served as the
coach of Mojave High School
since 2019
jones was fired following an
investigation launched this month
nevada is seeing green after
profits from legal
marijuana sales according to published figures
our state generated more than $1
billion in taxes in the past fiscal year,
an increase of 46
percent more than  the prior year which
was impacted by the pandemic the county
received nearly $800 million  s
of which 159 million were
distributed to school districts
across the state
after a difficult week
las vegas' stocks are looking to focus on their
upcoming game against the
denver broncos this sunday interim
coach page de sacher spoke for the
first time on wednesday  acknowledged the
controversy surrounding former coach
joan curen but stressed the importance
of taking responsibility
for one's actions the player
who still sees the only
openly gay player in the nfl asked
to take a day off to process
all that had happened  The
past few days
have been difficult years for teachers,
but despite this Wednesday, more than
140 teachers were honored for their
work and service at a retirement ceremony.
These educators offered
encouraging words for teachers
currently facing the challenges of
teaching during the pandemic.  the teacher
of the year juliana upv was present to
thank l  The educators and he said that
he will always advocate for the good of the teacher
and the day of the witches and Spain is
approaching his person is dressed in autumn ready
to scare in his hunter
harvest event for October 22 to 24 the
event is for the whole  family there will be
entertainment snacks and of course
vendors tickets are already on sale 9
dollars for adults and children
under 2 years old enter free you are asked to
buy your ticket before to reserve your
place
and we continue with the cold temperatures
today we will have a sunny day with  the
highs in the 70s we will see a small
increase for the weekend and
next time
I am cristian cásseres with his brief
informative of kirchner in spanish good
day
[Music]